pants compressed my name is Seb
today we're playing a BOSU which is
absolutely amazing I'm sure I'll be the
only one making that joke this was made
by a lot of people that worked on
journey and flour journey is one of my
favourite games of all time and I think
a lot of you who played it agree with me
and this is an absolutely fantastic game
it is perfectly paced I played it on my
channel ran it ready and if you don't
know about the game I highly recommend
you check it out but we're here with
Abzu right now which is supposed to be
in the same vein so I really expect
something really spectacular here if
it's even half of what journey was so
let's begin oh my god I love that color
of the ocean it's so pretty
already it's pretty now this game takes
place under the water under the sea I
wonder how many times I'll sing that I
will playing this this is gonna be a
full playthrough so if y'all tag along
I'll see you tomorrow with the new
episode I'm why am i already talking
about that oh my god how deep are we
going though I'm a bit scared of the
deep seas I don't know how I feel about
this this is a little too deep than I
would personally appreciate but maybe
it's a starting from the bottom kind of
thing you know maybe Drake will come out
who knows I am completely ruining this
game with my shitty jokes I'm so sorry
I'll just shut up
that was definitely Regina so I was just
thinking of the board's joke to follow
up with okay we're a diver
I knew that I've seen the trailer and
there's AI so cute
there we are
what I'm sue me I'm controlling I am
controlling this all right let's start
swimming whoa
this is cool man it's very simple
alright let's type sorry all right
Brenda the water
how long can I stay underwater boost oh
hell yeah
hey little fishies oh my god the fishes
AI not just call of duty
sweet sweet activation man
Fisher scare me I wouldn't just swim
through these guys hey there's the
grandpa fish how you doing buddy can I
go can I give you a kiss hold - what
already I'll try okay I am riding a
Goliath Grouper am i controlling it
though I suppose I am yeah all right
this is very different from oh my god
that is cool
so Brady I guess I still have the
talking option cuz that that was what
was in it about journey was that you
would just be selected with a random
player and you just have to figure [ __ ]
out by yourself oh my god it ate a fish
I can't really resurface calling all
fishes follow me hey I did him but how
about that just checking out the
controls I can interact right with who
who do I interact with there's something
over here lads I'm talking about the
fishes here we go
what is this oh I got one of those
diving what I wonder if they're gonna do
the same thing with journey I say David
journey where you get to play with a
friend
that's what made journey so special all
right I'm just gonna follow you know it
seems like it just follows me okay let's
go this way buddy hey it's you again
come on buddy let me Roger err weekend
oh my god
this guy is eating fishes is so hard to
control okay
how easy controls got it got him under
control now let's go buddy I'm gonna go
here to the light can't seem to be able
to do a look at sea horses let's eat
them now well welcome see if I care
can't go in here I guess we follow the
path yep let's go here oh we could
surface here but what's over the path no
there's another one there's a little
many places
okay got it all right I'm just gonna let
go of you you're annoying it's a little
weird to control man I don't know I
can't tell if I'm bad or if it's a gay
all right let's go up
nailed it good job kids now let's go ahh
hey I'm a dolphin dude I'm a freaking
dolphin man
all right let's do it here we go
yeah oh right okay I don't know why I
did that music is so pretty
alright here we go there's not something
else here another suppose we have to
activate all of them man I'm smart I
figured that one out all by myself guys
thank you very much though I don't need
your help please help me along the way I
would very much appreciate it okay so
I'm guessing me going to all these
places all this different places all
this hey we got bubbles a leopard shark
we just spawned a bunch of fishes guys
that is definitely a good thing why is
it talking to me
all right there we go another one all
right I got it
stop talking to me
here we go
we can't go through yet I think I assume
this is where I need to go but I don't
know if I can what do I need oh they
could just drill through it well pardon
me for not realizing I had to click on
it all right we're in guys
not a problem oh my god are we coming
out of like a mouth oh [ __ ] that is a
shake
oh I just got freaky
all right let's follow that buddy hello
oh [ __ ] the guy Elson step I love heels
hey you how you doing buddy you also
like the me me as fish on the sea man
every Google like eel I another shell
I'll take a thank you very much I'll do
a backflip for it there break out thank
you very much this is so cool I'm so
happy I'm playing this game right now
there's no other game I would rather be
playing than this game let's keep going
let's do a front-flip
hell yeah you saw that [ __ ] look at my
kneepads yeah that's right I call our
coordinate look I got six speed now whoa
whoa what is this
I can't seem to control the way I want
it hey let's do a flip you guys ready
for this
ah friend flip ha ha ha and then why
that's funny to do okay
let's go down deep what talking I don't
like I would get stark if I swear to God
it for like actual shark bites me I will
quit this game immediately what is this
oh it's just a portal that's not a big
deal
what hey it's the thing that means we're
in the bottom of the ocean now oh my god
what just happened what so pretty
Wow
can I talk to you
well
what is this place man ah [ __ ] obviously
I'm going to that one I'm sorry
the game pointed out pretty clearly well
don't worry I'll just swim there I got
SuperSpeed front flip hell yeah for my
robot friends come on any my robot
friends I miss them so much separation
anxiety kicks in what is do you
understand what the game is about cuz I
I totally do and you're kind of stupid
for not understanding the game this is
the blob of space and time of course
which I like to shower in occasionally
whoa okay why not
I did that
yep that's right I did that thank you
very much
hey stingrays look at letting go oh
that's a little disgusting it looks like
you're popping a pimple man sorry I'm so
sorry why do I always do that
door is open sure ready look at this
so amazing
can we meditate on the shark why have it
why am i excited about that
so you can just check out the fishes
that's what that's about so once I'm
done with this game my fish trivia is
going to be pretty insane that is of
course a uni crawl it's so good and this
of course is a rooster fish which you
can tell by its moist earnest so you can
tell this game is heavily on exploration
that robot just went straight through me
should we do an epic epic jump come on
let's get some speed betting let's get
some speed money
I can never really do it that good it
kind of pisses me off to be honest all
right let's go where we're supposed to
go sorry I'm taking too long I want to
ride the [ __ ] stingrays
are they could still called stingrays
when they're that huge what kind of
question is that
I don't know come on let me write you
better whoa man array that's what
they're called thank you game for
clarifying all right mister man array
would you mind coming with me mr. man
array I don't think you will
alright well then I'm sorry I gotta keep
going man a ring through this temple oh
they got jellyfishes and [ __ ] now
whoa this looks like hieroglyph but no
it looks like wall paintings [ __ ]
idiots
this is one of the most prettiest games
I have ever played it's really amazing I
hope it looks decent on YouTube I know
at my quality it's not always the best
oh it gets darker it gets darker where
are we going oh no my robot friend oh
I'll get you for this I swear I'll get
you for then the next episode holy [ __ ]
that was really cool I can't wait to
play more of this game I really hope you
enjoyed it as well thank you so much for
watching yet check out the game yourself
if you're interested really appreciate
that you brought you a lot of support
when we do a new series it's always cool
that you leave a like and all that stuff
I really really do appreciate it and
I'll see you bros tomorrow with another
episode and it's always stay awesome
rest George so I guess that's where the
star fell or what
I don't know I do
what are these migrate to I don't make
Nothing jumping sliding alright